I say let's go to central London where
we can speak to the community secretary
Robert generate thank you for being on
the program this morning at mr. Jam Rick
I just want to start with the
government's new slogan because when the
government told us to stay at home
protect the NHS save lives everyone knew
what that meant it was very effective
messaging it worked I have to be honest
now that stay at home has been replaced
with stay alert
in practical terms I don't really know
what that means can you explain well
good morning Sophie and I think as we've
now past the peak of the virus it's
right that we update and broaden the
message to the public I think that's
what the public want and that they will
be able to understand this message which
is that we should be staying at home as
much as possible but when we do go to
work and go about our business we need
to remain vigilant we need to stay alert
and that means things like respecting
others remaining two metres apart
washing your hands following the social
distancing guidelines because the virus
continues to be prevalent now too many
people are still dying of this and we're
going to have to live with it for a long
time
my point is slightly that stay alert is
so vague its bordering on being
meaningless I mean you could stay alert
while staying at home you could stay at
Lert and go to work you could stay alert
while having 20 of your friends over for
a party is there not a danger that this
is so Willie that it could apply to
anything well I hope not
you know the message that the public
have adhere to very well for the last
few weeks of staying at home now does
need to be updated we need to have a
broader message because we want to
slowly and cautiously restart the
economy and the country this will be a
cautious approach so you're sleeping
this evening well I won't react what the
prime is going to say tonight he's going
to be setting out the roadmap for the
weeks and months ahead but it will be
cautious we're not going to take risks
with the public's I understand people
are I are anxious about the future but
we want now to have
which encourages people to go to work as
we begin to ease some of the lockdown
measures to take advantage of those but
always to be cautious and to be alert
and that means as I've said continuing
to adhere to the social distancing
guidelines and staying at home will
still be an important part of the
message but you will be able to go to
work and you will in time be able to do
some other activities that you're not
able to do today okay I understand you
probably don't want to pre empty much of
what these are other activities so we'll
be and we've all seen the pictures over
the sunny bank holiday weekend
of people stretching the rules of the
lockdown in some cases pretty clearly
breaking the rules of the lockdown is
this not really the time to ditch the
stay at home message well as I've said
staying at home will still be a very
important part of our message to the
public but people will also need to go
to work they'll need to go and do
essentials like buying food and
medicines are looking after vulnerable
people where it's necessary and when
they do that they need to be responsible
and by and large in the vast majority of
the public are being responsible today
that's why the message that we've had
for the last few weeks has been
relatively successful it was important
that we had the parks open so that
people could get out and exercise and
could get some fresh air we want to see
that continue we want to give more
avenues for people to get out and about
so that life can be more livable and
more bearable as we learn to live with
the virus and move into the next phase
okay now you also introducing this new
five tier alert system for hope it 19 a
one to five scale can you explain
exactly what it is and how it would work
well I think many people will be
familiar with the threat level that
we've had in this country for some time
which measures the ongoing threat of
terrorists and and other risks to our
safety and this is a similar threat
level which will be known will be very
transfer
people will be able to see at what point
we are in controlling the virus at the
moment we believe the country is at four
on a scale of five with five being the
most concerning and our aspiration is to
bring that down as swiftly as we can to
three and add each stage at each of
those milestones we'll be in a position
to open up and restart more aspects of
the economy and of our lives we're going
to be rigorously monitoring our
performance against that and as I say
setting that out as transparently as we
can that will be done on a national
scale but the evidence behind that will
also be able to inform what we do at a
local level and if we see that there are
outbreaks in particular kalakeyas
neighborhoods schools towns then we may
be able to take particular measures in
those places as we build up a more
sophisticated and longer-term response
to controlling the virus interesting to
hear that there's going to be kind of a
regional aspect to it too and I just got
a quick question on the PM's road map
that he's gonna be setting out later I
know you're not going to want to go into
details and but can you just give us an
idea of the flavor of what he might say
but also crucially is this just going to
apply to England or will it also apply
to Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
well our strong preference is that the
whole United Kingdom moves as one and
the Prime Minister has been working
closely with the First Minister's and
you'll be speaking to some of them
shortly there'll be a cobra meeting
later today which will include them as
as always and we hope that they will
agree to a consistent approach across
the country that's our that's our strong
preference but the Prime Minister's
message and I won't preempt exactly what
he's going to say have to forgive me but
his message will be to thank the public
for adhering to the social distancing
guidelines over the last few weeks we
have now passed the peak the virus is on
a downward trend but it's still very
prevalent too many people are still
dying of this and so we have to adopt
the cautious approach that he's going to
be setting out
we will be looking to restart and reopen
the economy and the things that we all
miss in our daily lives but we were
doing that with great care and caution
and at every turn monitoring the impact
that has on the rate of the infection
within the community and the steps that
we take will be conditional on keeping
the virus under control if there are
outbreaks in one particular place or
another then we'll have the opportunity
to increase measures and control the
virus again this will be a cautious
approach but we know that the public are
anxious are concerned but equally want
to begin to get back to work
get back to their daily lives and just
listen to what you're saying there about
the rate of infection the our raid about
the one to five scale it's pretty clear
that the government's can be using data
as much as possible in the coming weeks
and months to inform policy so I just
want to have a look about where we are
when it comes to using that data and the
government's record on it you're
currently trialing a new NHS app on the
Isle of Wight which would alert you if
you come into contact with somebody with
coronavirus the FT reported on Friday
that we're now developing a second new
app complying slightly better with rules
from Apple and Google is that true is
there a second app because the first one
wasn't good enough
no we're piloting the app that we have
produced and we went down the path that
we did because we wanted an app that was
different to those that you've seen some
in other syrup are to the country over
parts of the world because it could have
more localised and therefore more useful
data that pilot I understand is going
well about 50,000 people already have
downloaded the app in just one week on
the Isle of Wight so you know that's a
great response and we're very great I
think that's that's about 40% of of the
population on the on the Isle of Wight
so that's that's a very strong rumor
this is only in a week so we're very
grateful for Islanders for responding so
well I hope more listen to this program
and in the days ahead that will download
the app and we'll get up to our target
but we're also it is correct that we all
also looking at what other countries are
doing and if we need to learn lessons
from those obviously we will do we want
to have the most effective app that we
can possibly have and we'll learn from
the pilot in the Isle of Wight before we
roll this out across the rest of the
country so it could change then
effectively the app because of the
minute the data is stored centrally in
the app behalf but there is pressure to
perhaps have a decentralized approach
because of privacy concerns isn't that
well well this is a pilot and as I say
the what one of the things appear to be
going well with the pilot is that many
people are downloading it we saw
somebody well its beat with respect so
if it's been it's been a week and we've
got 50,000 people who have already
downloaded on the Isle of Wight so I
think that's that's very good progress
we hope we'd get more in the next few
days but we'll learn from that pilot and
then we'll roll it out across the rest
of the country ok now you're also hiring
18,000 people to do contact tracing
which is another important part of
course of the test track and trace
approach that the government want to see
in the coming months so how many have
been hired so far we don't have a figure
or I don't have a figure for that this
morning but we are hiring those
individuals we're building the network
across the country we're working now
with local councils as well so that we
can use their expertise the public
health experts that they have as well
that with the pilot on the Isle of Wight
and with the increasing capacity within
testing is building the network that we
will need as an essential element of our
strategy moving forward to control the
virus and to have the best possible data
as to its progress in all parts of the
country and we're going to be announcing
later today the primers will be saying
more that there'll be a Center for
biosecurity that will bring this data
together monitor the progress against
the virus in all parts of the country
and inform our response if as I say
we're able to move to the next level
on the scale that we're setting out or
if there are particular places that
might need more measures put in place to
protect the public
there and prevent the an outbreak
broadening beyond one neighborhood or
locality okay pretty clear that the
government doesn't want to tell us how
many people have been hard to say far
for the contact tracing and how about
the testing because that of course is
another big part of it people getting
the test to show whether or not you have
corona virus the government did hit its
hundred thousand tested a target but
then missed it for seven days in a row
is it true that tens of thousands of
tests were sent to America because of
problems in UK labs well testing
capacity is over a hundred thousand now
that's a huge increase from a month ago
you know we've gone month by month from
two thousand capacity to ten thousand to
a hundred thousand capacity and now
we're moving forwards and the Prime
Minister and the health sector has had a
target of two hundred thousand so we are
making good progress there and that's a
level of testing that's comparable with
other countries in Europe and around the
world who have good responses to the
virus there was an issue with one of the
labs and we put in place our contingency
plan which was to take some of the tests
to the United States for the testing
process and that was exactly in line
with the detailed plans that the
Department for Health had made in
advance and actually just demonstrates
the fact that we're so determined to
increase the amount of testing that
we'll do steps like that to get the test
results done you know wherever that
needs to be done and get those results
back to members the public as quickly as
we can okay now what are the things that
of course is really important in the
government's response is tracking the
Arnim but the rate of infection
effectively how many people each
infected person passes the virus on to
and if it becomes more than one then
that's very troubling indeed and so some
are asking what if whether or not that's
ticked up in the last few days in the
last days which is limited what the
government can do say can you just tell
me what is the our number and
specifically what is the our numbering
care homes well the the Prime Minister
will set out more about the rate of
infection and how we intend to monitor
that later today the our number is is
arranged today
the last scientific evidence I saw was
it was between nought point six and
naught point nine there are different
rates of infection within the community
and within care homes as indeed there
are different rates of infection
different parts of the United Kingdom so
it's not quite as simple as just saying
there's one our number for the whole
country but the important thing as you
say is that we control the virus so that
the rate of infection doesn't rise above
one and then starts to grow what is it
ventually and that's at the heart that's
at the heart of our strategy can you
tell me what it is in care homes the the
our number is I don't I don't have the
exact figure for the our number within
care homes but we do believe that the
rate of it we've passed or passing
through the peak of the infection within
care homes okay and that we're starting
to be on a downward trend within care
homes that doesn't that doesn't you know
that's not to downplay what's happening
in care homes because it's a very
challenging situation there and that's
why we're putting in place a
comprehensive coherent strategy for care
homes the testing of patients and
residents including the asymptomatic new
discharge policies that the NHS doesn't
bring people back to care homes unless
it's clear they're free of covert more
personal protective equipment and
ensuring this more support both in terms
of NHS local council and financial
support for care homes across the
country so that we can wrap our arms
around them in the days and weeks ahead
you say that you want to wrap your arms
around care homes now but I just wonder
if the government has done enough to
wrap its arms around care homes in the
past and the reason that I'm focusing on
care homes is you'll know is because
frankly what's been happening there is
pretty heartbreaking one of the
government successes is the fact that
the NHS hasn't been overwhelmed but
we've seen cases before where older
people vulnerable people have been sent
back to care homes from hospital even
some with coronavirus which is then
spreading care homes so my question to
you is has care homes been sacrificed in
order to protect the NHS
No and we are putting in place the
measures that we need to to address some
of the concerns that you've just
outlined for example better discharge
policies so that you don't return to a
care home until you're free of
coronavirus or 14 days have passed less
movement of staff between care homes so
that you can limit people coming into
care homes who might have coronavirus
for example without knowing it if they
were asymptomatic all the symptoms
hadn't yet manifested themselves and you
know a bigger package of support for
care homes it was always going to be
more challenging to support Kem's
there's more than 15,000 of them across
the country they're in many different
hands you know many of them are
privately Lea owned but we're now
ensuring that there are the procedures
in place there's better support from the
NHS from GPS district nurses local
councils and also that they've got the
financial support as well to ensure that
they are the amazing work that's going
on there can be sustainable in the
longer term